this is jeffrey
tom i'll start with you if that's okay
he's an nba owner
a self-taught guitarist and has guest
starred in both the office
and game of thrones
he's unhappy with his boss and has no
options who is
aaron rodgers ding ding that is correct
well done it's a projection time i never
said i'm unhappy with my boss
i said it not you
[Laughter]
aaron he taught himself algebra at the
age of six he streams on twitch
under the handle the bad one 23
and can sign his autograph backwards
with his left hand bill are you on
twitch
i don't think i think that's my teammate
uh
bryson dichambo
that would be correct well done bryson
this is one this one's for you here
oh boy he was a four-time all-america
selection
has the middle name alfred
and is right-handed
oh my gosh i got no idea um
i'm taking a complete guess on this i
don't know why
no way it's my partner who is there
who's aaron i don't know it is who is
phil mickelson actually did you know
philly
phil was right-handed phil you never
told me that you son of a gun
bryson i got i got some news for you i
hate to tell you this
phil doesn't like you yes i love bryce
what are you talking about i love the
guy
i didn't know that she had to be
terrible at jeopardy i'm more of a wheel
of fortune guy
oh sorry aaron no that's not a knock on
aaron at all
teammate infighting already i don't like
it okay
that's what we want division from within
i want to talk trash to somebody in this
group so if it has to be bryson so be it
i got i got one more question this is
for phil phil the answer
to the question is we're looking for the
question but the answer is
he led the new england patriots to six
super bowls
architect of one of the greatest
dynasties in the history of sports
and is known far and wide as the goat
tom brady is ago they also call him the
man they both
seem to apply and
he's also my partner and i love it most
importantly can you
form your answer in the phrase of a
question honestly the question is
who is the goat but also known as
the man and
time's up yeah
[Laughter]
that wasn't double jeopardy we'd be
broke are you are you saying who is tom
brady
i am saying who's tom brady oh no phil
i'm sorry that would be bill belichick
i don't know how'd that go aaron i know
i let you have there's a little style
with the incorrect answer you don't want
to shame the guy but you also want to
make sure you get it right and aaron was
a
he was amazing by the way he was and
just like just like everything else he
does i know phil you probably
you probably watch it's a little too
intelligent for you but um
uh but thank you tom
you